[Music]
if you keep yourself in pretty good
shape
I try to you know I work out I think
maybe that's okay my wife's up here and
I'm here but maybe by working out all
the time
yeah you're definitely inching closer in
for real we were eating dinner and I out
of nowhere because I I'm well documented
I love Mel bodies as I love women's
bodies I just love the human farm and so
I happen to notice when we're eating
dinner I was like your chest is really
kind of protruding and what's great
about noticing men's bodies is you can
immediately touch I was like man are you
working out and I was feeling your body
like nice delts yeah I see how it women
all the time I can't manhandle them yeah
but soon as I noticed you had been
pumping iron I got in there and I felt
everything I wanted to feel yeah he did
puppet 70 you were just everywhere it's
probably more it's probably more like
the meat department at route okay just
checking out all the cut I was I spent
30 seconds probably feeling you yeah
right it is normal everyone else was
fine with it yeah I wanted to see what
was happening with your wife but I
didn't yeah that's right cuz you don't
do that we agree we were gonna leave her
out of it and that body and how I mean
you didn't feel Kristen either
no I didn't all right as a gentleman
yeah and I also didn't reach over and
feel you because I didn't want to and I
accepted if you want to set up a swinger
thing you should probably do it by email
yeah hey you don't bring it up here on
the show I don't know I think that meant
kinds a great way to break the ice okay
it could be a joke there's a comedy show
right yeah sorry I said I wanted to get
you on our wives together
on that comedy program of yours I was
just teasin unless you think that's a
good idea
oh you're so sex positive yes what does
that mean um sex positive means like you
know we can talk about anything sexual
and it's like a no-judgment zone so
whatever you're into it's not like you
or that's weird or why you into that
it's more like we just embrace it and we
talk about it and it's very educational
I don't know if you guys have any
questions but I'm just curious well I do
I mean we're thinking about having an
orgy
Conine our wives on retainer so I'm just
wondering if you would you advise this
for us we're both happily married yeah I
would say if everyone is comfortable
with the situation always use a new
condom for each woman oh I don't want to
wear a condom yet okay
[Applause]
Christon have you asked her at all about
any of this I think she feels
comfortable with it just guessing sounds
like a big no to me
you